assalamualaikum which is a greetings of
peace I'm here at the Muslim Community
Center in Chicago we have a wonderful
group of people coming in to learn about
Islam and Muslims we're going to help
answer their questions clear up the
misconceptions come with us and enjoy
[Music]
foreign
I know
[Music]
do you guys like that
it's not peaceful huh it's beautiful
I have no doubt that because it will be
a successful project Insha'Allah I've
had the blessing of knowing brother
Eddie since he started the dean show and
he's one of the most sincere and most
dedicated people to the Darwin that I
have ever met so please do support the
dean Center
[Music]
it's great to see that you guys are like
tight community and everything I really
like that would you recommend others to
come or I would recommend others there
there was a time when I think our um
our students will be worried about the
fact they're coming that they be coming
here and they're not now they're they're
prepared and they're looking forward to
it we've learned a lot yeah I enjoyed it
a lot yeah it was fun getting to see um
new religion and stuff like that
and yes experiencing stuff it's very
enriching
definitely changes your opinion on
things instead of seeing the news every
day
I didn't know that the uh that the angel
Gabriel was considered to be something
different a holy spirit so to so to
speak
um I I just heard that that he he was
one who gave the gave the message to
Muhammad but that was all I knew about
that we learned
[Music]
I mean a lot of things that were touched
about like the angel Gabriel and like
the uh I didn't know a lot about that
and um like the sacraments and stuff so
yeah thank you nice to meet you guys I
actually have been to a mosque in Israel
before and so like kind of experiencing
like an American style was like it's
very casual and
um I really enjoyed it a lot
would you recommend others absolutely
yeah definitely I was telling the
students at the table they were asking
about young people
and I was sharing that the law when we
when we were here in November there were
I don't know four or five teenage guys
at the end of the row who
seemed to be sort of doing things that
every group of teenagers use on a youth
group any place banging into each other
and but then they get serious and it was
just really cool and I started to
investigate all the different religions
and I came to conclude that Islam
provided me with all the evidence and
all the proof that it was indeed a way
of life that I wanted to live by that it
was the truth and then there was all
these different things associated with
Islam
terrorism oppression of women and the
list goes on but then I was saying that
Islam was promoting peace Justice mercy
and love
and I was like hold on
am I going to let Fox News Sean Hannity
and all these other people speak up for
the Muslims or I'm going to go ahead and
be a good ambassador to Islam so then we
started a program called the dean show
now you guys if you have the uh Facebook
YouTube you can go ahead and look it up
it's called the dean show and we do a
weekly program here on cantv 36 in
Chicago but if you subscribe you can go
ahead and see our shows weekly and it's
dedicated to clearing the many
misconceptions that are out there
about Islam and Muslims this is the
first time visiting a mosque how many
were kind of nervous
not too many I had an opportunity to
travel to Colorado not too long ago and
I met up with a pastor and I was
finished giving the what they called the
sermon The Talk The Hooda and then the
sir the pastor came up to me and he
introduced himself and I asked him the
same question
and he said the first time he came in he
was terrified he was terrified I said
how do you feel now I see he says I feel
at home and he just comes to hang out
so I'm glad you guys are here but what
that reminded me of is the reality
of the propaganda that's out there
that's helping to Foster fear
misunderstanding and how much this work
is important of us conveying the true
Message of Islam and you guys also
hopefully going from here with a better
understanding and then when you're at
the dinner table
or you're at school and then you hear
somebody else you guys will be the
ambassadors also a piece to help stop
the lies and the false information
because here you'll actually learn about
Muslims in Islam from The Source not
from the Hate Machine now back in 19
6 Time Magazine did an article
and they had conveyed the reality over a
span of 150 years
from 18
00 to 1950 that over 60
000 books were written against Islam
these this is before Facebook this is
for social media so there were 60
000 anti-islam books written against
Islam so you can imagine the propaganda
started way before now so that's one
book a day so those are the books that
many people are still reading to this
day now add on top of that
add on top of that now what we have of
social media and how easily a lie can
spread from here to China in a matter of
minutes seconds
have heard the word Jihad
huh
so how many of you know what the word
Jihad means
holy war you see okay that's one good
job next one anybody else
okay so we got uh holy war we got
pilgrimage we'll go one more
anybody else
want to give it a try
I put him on the spot huh right in the
middle of a bite
that's good hey okay so imagine hearing
look now because many Muslims name their
kids Jihad many Muslim you guys actually
how many how many of you guys struggled
I mean to get up in the morning
huh how many to get to school
what if I told you you actually do Jihad
every day maybe to struggle and strive
because that's what it literally means
to struggle and strive against evil one
of the greatest jihads now is to
struggle and strive now to be a good
decent morally upright human being how's
that sound
would I be lying on if I said Jesus did
Jihad would I sister
no
huh our sister now many many the the
attack that's on Muslim sisters and let
me just go on a tantrum here anybody
know what a Muslim means what does it
mean Islam and Muslim let's give it a
try
let's see anybody at this give me a
raise a hand what does Islam mean
because I'm going to be using these
words and now I want to clear because I
can say a word and then you might have
all these different connotations
ascribed to it so that's kind of and and
a picture that's a false picture so
let's go ahead and put everything in the
right context anybody Islam what's your
name what's it mean
[Music]
how about Muslim what does it mean
how important
first how many have heard that you've
obviously heard the word Islam right
everybody you've heard the word Islam
but let's be honest what come and we we
got to be honest with each other
okay if we're gonna move forward we
gotta start our relationship right
so it's good to have a good relationship
based on honesty all right so I'll be
honest with you good good okay
now
if we're gonna start off this
relationship will start it off right and
now if we have this word Islam that's
constantly in the media what do you
usually what comes to mind this is an
easy one now I know you're going to get
this when you hear Islam what comes to
mind
right next to it what's the word I'll
give you a hint T begins with a T
ah how about Muslim Muslim
what comes along with that usually huh
anybody
come on don't be afraid now
Muslim and I'll give you another one t
are you guys look shy huh
but Muslim is one who has chosen
to freely
consciously submit his or her will to
the creator of the heavens and earth
this is what a Muslim is and Islam is
to do that submission so Islam peace
acquired by submitting your will to the
will of
who
to do
Allah Allah and Allah equals
like in the Lord's Prayer o Our Father
who art in heaven Hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come thy will be done thy
will be done we will say this is Islam
to submit your will to the will of the
creator of the heavens and earth to
worship the one God and to be morally
upright this is what Islam means this is
it
isn't that a better picture
huh
can I get amen
all right so we got we got those two
words Muslim one who submits to the will
of God doing Islam submitting his or her
will because every day you're tempted to
maybe submit to your desires to submit
to a human being
a lot of times you got to break the
first Idol which is with which is within
yourself
so a muslim's whole life is now doing
Jihad
not to submit to anything to the
corruption a lot of times that's out
there to be a good decent human being
according to whose game plan
God's game plan
so now
we go ahead and we Define these words
and we talk about what Islam is so then
we can understand clearly what it isn't
now usually before we even get
to the six pillars
the six articles of Faith so there's six
articles of faith in Islam
and then there's five pillars but
usually before you even get to this now
the human being is asking or should be
asking the question like why am I here
what's the purpose of life why have I
been created
you get past all the new atheism
beautiful
documented to me that I really really
call everyone to watch is called
expelled no intelligence allowed has
anybody
watch this I believe it's by some
Christians who put it together possibly
it's called intelligence
no intelligence allowed or expelled no
intelligence allowed it's actually a
movie that has been created to really
create this awareness because you guys
you guys are in the universities now
right College universities and you will
see attack because you guys come from a
Christian University right but you will
see that many of the University you have
the institutions set up to push subtly
to make fun of you know I just heard a
story of it was a arts class and they
had the teacher arts teacher and they
were showing uh Mary the mother of Jesus
and Jesus and then they were suddenly
coming in and saying you know because
they were talking about how Jesus she
married the mother of Jesus how she had
Jesus without a father it is one of the
Miracles and then the professors here
laughing about how can this happen this
is ridiculous whoever believes this and
the yada and that's puts the doubts in
you or do you go to the university and
on the wall it's written here no God God
God does not exist and then usually what
happens is the professor asks how many
people believe in God and there'll be
some Christians maybe a couple Muslims
and they'll raise their hands has
anybody had this happen to them have you
heard of this these are true stories
and then at the beginning the majority
raised their hands and then they begin
and then the semester ends
have you heard about these stories
sister and then what happens at the end
they now the professor the philosophy
professor says how many now believe in
God
and now it's like from a classroom maybe
90 raise their hands and then at the end
maybe two
you see so the person who's a true
Seeker asking these questions like she
did like I did like you guys are doing
you're asking what's the purpose of life
why am I here you start to think
Aristotle and Plato they were the ones
who argued by design design indicates a
designer the cosmological argument you
think okay
nothing comes from nothing for something
exists there has to be a cause nothing
can just come from nothing
Isaac Newton he argued the fine-tuning
argument
like a fine-tuned clock he compared the
universe amazing so when you use this
groupers the common sense but it's kind
of a shame that common sense is not
always common practice but you use the
common sense it leads you
to the conclusion that there has to be a
Creator and then we have the morality
argument and all these other things now
you don't get sucked into the whole
atheism and all this other thing that's
out there and now you start to look for
the way of life
that's based on proof and evidence and
now we find out hold on
God Almighty over time he sent
Messengers and this now we get into the
belief system
and the six articles of Faith Have You
Ever Seen The Passion of the Christ have
you seen The Passion of the Christ Mel
Gibson he wanted to go back and make it
as authentic as possible and if you can
go you just type in you know Passion of
the Christ and you'll see they have
subtitles when the one part of the scene
where Jesus
he would he was calling on God he was
saying Allah
sounds pretty similar it's a lot doesn't
it so this is not a different God this
is not a many people another
misconception is a moon God
so this is
the name for God the god in the Arabic
language so an Aramaic
Hebrew Elohim Jehovah this is the one
God so I want to go back to the first
pillar
the first pillar of Islam submission to
the will of the Creator not the creation
and I want because sometimes we can get
inundated with a lot of information but
if you guys leave with anything I really
want you to remember this the main
Message of Islam was the message that
came with the first man Adam
he was called to submit his will to the
one God
and then God Almighty out of his love
he's a God Allah who wants to guide
Humanity he loves Humanity for God so
loved the world that he sent prophets
and Messengers and they all came with
the same message calling Humanity to
have a loving peaceful relationship with
the one God to submit their will to the
one God to worship the Creator not the
creation that was the crust of the
message and to be morally upright and if
you leave with anything
I want you guys to leave with this to
remember this because Islam is easy to
understand say what did you learn about
it well they talked about worshiping one
and only one God and being morally
upright that's the main Message of Islam
so I really want you to watch this
program I did with the Christian his
name is Owen Benjamin I have him on the
dean show if you go into my channel
thedeaneshow.com you can go to my
YouTube channel and there's a great talk
I did with a Christian we went back and
forth back and forth now this guy have
you guys ever heard of Joe Rogan
of course he's probably the most watched
or most listened to watch podcast he was
on The Joe Rogan show he was a Hollywood
actor comedian and he was really
infamous
for
spreading hate about Islam and Muslims
but then he had an epiphany he started
to really look into Islam he started to
what really fascinated him was every
time the Muslims say Jesus we say peace
be upon him he was like why am I hating
on these people they elevate Jesus peace
be applied to such a high level and they
always say peace be upon him and then he
started to really look into it and he
changed his ways and then we were
talking about because he lives on the
farm over there in Washington somewhere
he's got some gold whatnot and we had a
great conversation I want you guys
really to watch that his name is Owen
Benjamin on the diesel now going back to
the first
first
pillar of Islam so you imagine this line
and these Messengers five of the great
I'll mention there continue with their
names Noah same thing calling Humanity
to have a loving peaceful relationship
to acquire that peace that we all want
that contentment that solace
by doing what God wants us to do
submitting our will to the Creator not
the creation obeying him if we make a
mistake we turn back to the all-loving
the most merciful
and then we try not to go back to the
sin or to what displeases God but we
keep striving forward and then another
messenger comes and it keeps going on
and on and on until the final messenger
we say Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him now it's
interesting as our sister talked about
the shahada if you are living during the
time of Abraham Abraham would come with
the message
because this chain was always lived
together and it's what's beautiful is
when the chronological order where you
can piece all this together it just
makes sense
so now
Moses would come Abraham and you
couldn't bypass them they were the way
the truth and the light so you had to
accept Abraham
as a messenger and then you would make
the shahada
there's no God but one God there's
nothing worthy of worship except the one
God and Abraham is his messenger Now we
move on to the other ones Noah same
thing
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the Creator and Moses is the messenger
same thing during the time of Jesus and
then during the time of Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him so that's
really a really interesting interesting
thing that really kind of puts some
light on things and makes things kind of
less confusing and this is something
that really if you guys leave with
remember this part this first one that's
so so important so I'll open it up now
where we shared a lot we got about how
many five minutes until
10 minutes does anybody have any
questions I want to just jump into to
one thing because we heard the word
terrorism
you know Islam anybody running around
machete
stabbing up people shooting up people
innocent people he's actually doing a
Jihad for Satan did you know that you
could do a Jihad for Satan right so now
this has become something that's so so
much on the minds of people thinking
that before I come into mosque what is
it a bob-making factory are these guys
are they partnering and planting this
that and the other but this is one thing
one of probably the biggest
misconceptions that people have about
Muslims in Islam is this whole
terrorism thing
how many
as I said earlier I mentioned how many
people watch the news and have heard
something linked back to this
yeah
so my question usually is how can
someone have a loving peaceful
relationship with the Creator if they're
spreading hate Terror
in the world doesn't make sense
you know there's a beautiful passage in
the Quran where God Almighty is saying
that killing one this is the meaning
killing one innocent being is as if you
kill the world saving one innocent life
is as if you saved the world you know we
started off the meeting with peace be
with you
so Muslims are people who try to spread
peace have peace with their creator and
when that resonates in your heart when
you have that naturally you can give
what you have you have that you yet that
Persona that energy so this is something
that is so important that we kind of
clear these things out of our minds
and we'll have some pamphlets also
that when you guys come out you can go
ahead
and pick up some of these Jesus a
messenger of God the Quran and science
on what I just covered Islam
on extremism Islam on women all these
different topics that we have and then
also if you guys are more visual you can
go on YouTube Type in the dean show I
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in and see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you we've been
told that uh they're out to kill us all
brothers and sisters we went to the
streets to ask Americans about Islam
here's what they said do you know
anything about Islam No do you know
anything about Islam No sadly do you
know anything about Islam uh not really
do you know anything about Islam
no I'm sorry you know what Islam means
Islam uh no we've been told that uh
they're out to kill us all right that's
what you've been told that Muslims are
out to kill you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you can have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click to donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign thank you